now you but let me I want to get to this
too is that you're Asian you're half so
do all the parts to you audition for
that are the Asian or this regular right
he was the Gina Gershon sister right I'm
not exactly sure you're the first person
who's told me flat-out Lindsay you're
Asian remember we spoke about it when I
came to see your show and I don't know
what people see cuz like you know and
you're like you're Asian you were ugly
you're like you're Asian
yeah is Barack Obama black he's the
generation right right and I'm but the
parts that I plate look in the early
years my brother and I cuz my brother
was an actor too we cornered the market
on like there was like this trend where
all this shows the TV shows were doing a
storyline about like the bastard
children from like the G I would go to
all the other half parades would be like
twice kids are here they'd like believe
because we were like clearly yeah but
when that was over it became like this
nonspecific fill in the you know like I
was like the diversity and that was a
million years ago and still I'd say
today like we know that were sometimes
cast for our diversity I think I'm a
really at some points like the shows
that I was on the billboards and the bus
stops for yeah I was like a homogenized
version of something ethnic so to make
people feel comfortable but it wasn't a
completely whitewashed show but I was
like an easy I think that's interesting
that they would hire you and then they
would think of like we need a fat asian
guy but it's I think it yeah in my head
I'm like yeah when I saw you for the
first time I'm like yeah she's Asian
you know I'll give you an example some
yeah if you have a glass you take a
everyone tried this experiment at home
okay take a glass take a glass a
see-through glass do it right yeah fill
it halfway with water okay then fill it
halfway with coke okay what is the color
it's not water anymore call it it's not
water it took like yeah it's cookie
still a coke it's a coke yeah well it's
watery coke asian light yeah but then I
met your brother
and he's very more Asian yeah so then I
saw he looks super Korean he we I showed
the kids like a little bit of the show
and they're like what's uncle Peter on
the show screenshot my you know how like
the creepy thing happens on your iPhone
work like categorizes your pictures yes
you're in like my favorites because the
iPhone thinks you're like related to me
it's like you my mom my dad races Apple
I don't know what it was but that's what
it was I have two pictures of Bobby by
the way that's amazing yeah yeah my
brother looks yeah genetics you know
okay cuz I know that you and I you know
we've talked when we should shut the
show and then you have that time you
know you're waiting for it to come out
about the show about like it did well
yeah it's hard to write let's just say
it's great it's amazing shut the [ __ ] I
saw King I saw all I loved it
I'm sorry I saw an I love again you did
I did why did you love it I don't know I
almost I feel like any all the other
family shows that are out there it's up
there with like feel good and there's a
lot of stuff on TV that's not so more
than just feel good it gives you the
feels yes it gives you the oh [ __ ]
I have felt that thing at that exact
moment in that way before which is what
the whole point I mean that's the whole
point with movies and television is you
want to sit there and and relate and
like that's like the age-old thing of
storytelling which means I think that
it's really written well but it's making
people like get stirred up and like few
things because it feels authentic so I'm
excited to be on it for that reason
yeah how many things have you done where
you're like this is just so false and it
doesn't feel you don't feel good about
it
yeah I feel
really good about the show I do you do I
do pilot called new car smell I'm sure
that was us that's the one that you
worked yeah yeah yeah would you want
that yeah yeah boy yeah but I I tend to
not let myself get super excited cuz
I've been around see that's what I'm
friends you just manage your
expectations you have to because you
never know you know like it's all so
fleeting
it's also like it's not there's nothing
permanent about any of it my friend
Johnny texted me today and he said he
saw today s bling up together commercial
oh and it said our new hit show man
everyone's talking about it to me but I
know I'm in it so of course they're you
know but like people are saying that
they really liked it
[Music]